I was doing set The Laugh Factory I was
crossing Fairfax and a guy had had like
a like a pitbull puppy it was fine until
I got within like a few feet from it and
then it jumped up and actually got my
neck it was like this moment of oh okay
I have to be aware that could take me
out one day like if I'm around a big dog
I'm not overly cautious that could
totally be the thing that kills me yeah
I mean I was I was at my friend Sam's
house and her dog was the rescue dog
who's real possessive and the man that
house wasn't homes what's up the dog
went crazy it's right right and jumping
up and what he was jumping up and
fighting me hard on the ass my ass is
like so they could totally come up and
do some shake I just was scared of dog
an especially big dogs like this one can
do a lot more damages on a piece of [ __ ]
is that your only fear it fears of
failure and stuff I did three episodes
of legit this season and I pull out a
banana Jim Jeffries he's afraid of
bananas very uncomfortable around them
like he asked if he has to leave like I
had to leave with my banana Wow ie I
wanted to know what it was because I'm
fascinated by that like how people also
have a fear of bananas but but he
totally does I don't know what it is